.
STEVE: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
PROMISED SEVERE PUNISHMENT FOR
SAUDI ARABIA OVER THE MURDER OF
JOURNALIST JAMAL KHASHOGGI AND
DOESN'T WANT TO PUT NATIONAL
SECURITY OR JOBS AT RISK.
FINE.
OUR MUCH VAUNTED PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE SAUDIS HASN'T
PREVENTED THE TOTAL MESS THE
INVOLVEMENT FOR THE MIDDLE EAST
HAS BEEN FOR HALF A CENTURY AND
THE DEFENSE INDUSTRY FROM
PROFITING FOR ARMS SALES IS THE
SINGLE MOST CORRUPT AND
WASTEFUL CORNER OF THE D.C.
SWAMP.
ANYWAY, THE OTHER WAY FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO DELIVER A
BLOW MAKING US SAFER.
SAUDIS HAVE BEEN THE MAIN
FUNDERS OF RADICAL ISLAM BASED
ON MEDIEVAL INTERPRETATION OF
ISLAM, WAHHABISM.
MAKE THEM PAY FOR THE
PRIVILEGE.
MAKE THEM PAY REPARATIONS FOR
THEIR ROLE IN RADICAL ISLAM.
MAKE THEM PAY FOR A NEW GLOBAL
NETWORK OF MODERATE MOSQUES AND